This month, many countries around the world will be spreading awareness on multiple
sclerosis, or "MS".  A disease that
affects millions of people worldwide.  But
what exactly is multiple sclerosis? MS primarily affects the central
nervous system which consists of the
brain, spinal cord and optic nerve.  Just
about everything you do depends on this
system functioning properly, from
breathing to moving and even watching
youtube videos.  And these actions are all
facilitated by neurons throughout your body,
cells which we've talked about many
times in our previous videos.  These
neurons are able to send signals all
throughout the body at incredible
speeds, in part because of the fatty
coating that surrounds them
something called myelin or the myelin sheath.
This myelin insulates the impulses and
allows the nerve signals to reach their
destination, however in the case of
MS this is where the issues occur.
The immune system is designed to fight
off disease from viruses, bacteria,
parasites or other agents and does so by
distinguishing these things from healthy
tissue.  But in the case of MS, the immune
system ends up attacking the myelin in
what is classified as an auto-immune disorder.
This process of de-myelination can lead
to a build above scar tissue, hence the
word sclerosis.  The CNS then becomes
unable to send and receive signals
properly.  Messages traveling along
neurons may be slowed down, distorted or
stopped altogether.  Because of the
bearing, locations and nature of de-myelination,
the symptoms of MS are
incredibly diverse.  They can range from
muscle weakness to decreased coordination,
fatigue, vision problems, numbness or even
paralysis.
Though an MRI scan of the brain to
look for lesions or scarring is integral
to diagnosis.
For some, the symptoms come as acute
episodes while others experience more
chronic and permanent symptoms, which
worsen over time.  At this point no true
cause or cure is known.  While potential
links to environmental factors, viral
infections and genetics have been found,
studies are ongoing and not yet
conclusive.  And while their has been a lot of work
towards not only alleviating some of the
symptoms but slowing the progression,
sadly these treatments do not work for
all MS sufferers. Ultimately, bringing
like to this issue in an effort to
support and fund research is an
incredibly important step to erasing MS.
And though many of us will
never truly understand the challenges of
living with MS,
we can work together to raise awareness.
We would be so grateful if you could
take a moment and pass this video on to
your family and friends and join in the
effort to end MS.
This episode of AsapSCIENCE is supported by
23andMe.  23andMe is a
DNA analysis service that allows you
to explore your own genes, whether you're
interested in discovering a global
origins for understand you're health and your
risk for disease, be they sure to check out
23andme.com/asap
With the help of their DNA kits, connect to
your past, learn about your present health and
potentially be a part of future genetic research
all at 23andme.com/asap
And subscribe for more weekly science videos.